Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawkode.
Today we are gonna be taking a look
at Fluentd and Fluent Bit logging systems for
Kubernetes and other platforms.
And today, I am lucky enough to be
joined by two members of the Fluent team,
Anurag and Eduardo. Hello. How are you both?
Doing well. Doing well. Glad to be here.
And, David, thanks for the invitation. Happy to
be here.
Awesome. I'm excited.
Why don't we start?
Just take a little bit of a moment.
You can both introduce yourself,
and then we'll talk a little bit about
the projects.
Sure. I can start. So,
yeah, Anurag
Gupta,
used to be a product manager in Azure
where I got exposed to a bunch of
open source and and worked on open source
team there, including the project Fluentd,
which we ended up using for our Azure
log analytics
service that we ran in Azure.
It was awesome, and then got invited by
treasury data to come and
actually help help help out with Fluentd. So
I left that in 2017,
And then did a brief stint at Elastic
as well, so I was a product manager
at Elastic. So logging has been
part of part of the journey for for
the past seven years, and really excited just
to come back to Fluentd, Fluent Bit, cloud
native space, and see see how they evolve
it.
Great. My name is Eduardo Silva,
and I have been involved with the Fluentd
team for about
seven years, I think, as of now.
And
one I I started working for Trisha Data
at that point to to help with the
Fluentd project
together as a team. We started Fluent Bit.
With the time we met Anurag.
Right? And have have been involved with the
crisis then. We have been working
very heavily with the CNCF,
with the other projects, and with the whole
ecosystem.
Nice. Excellent.
So I believe we have a couple of
slides and some some materials we're gonna go
through to tell us a little bit about
what the projects are.
Yeah. Definitely.
Awesome. So, yes, I thought it'd be good
just to give a little bit of an
intro
for those who who aren't aware what Fluentd
and Fluent Bit are
and just kinda, know, give you a bit
of an overview, what the use cases are,
how you can leverage it kinda within your
your enterprise,
your data center, within, you know, your your
environment.
So let's first start and zoom out with
some of the challenges that we have with
data, and I think this is probably something
a lot of us can relate with is
you just have this ever expanding expanding
amount of data sources. Right? You have Kubernetes.
All of a sudden,
developers are being asked to start doing security.
You have system logs. You have networks that
that can be
short lived. You have application logs.
Each of these need to be routed to
different outputs, so you might have security folks
that care about
having all of this in Splunk. You might
have folks that care about all of this
in Elasticsearch.
You have new outputs like Grafana's low key
coming out on the scene. You have s
three, MongoDB,
all sorts of these different outputs. You have
all sorts of formats.
So every log that you're writing has, you
know, potentially a different format, whether it's JSON,
whether it's application specific.
And then on top of kind of all
these challenges where you have, you know, f
number of sources and n number of outputs,
you need to make sure that all of
the data that you're trying to ship from
point a to point b
can handle failures,
can handle network outages, you know, potentially going
to the cloud so it can go through
a load balancer. It can buffer that data
so in case something
automatically
shuts off, you don't lose all that data.
So you need a lot of resilience now
with with all of these things.
And just to kind of
showcase two of these challenges, one around the
sources.
The the the aren't just files.
You also have places like Kubernetes
where you have tons and tons of applications
that might be running in it. It might
have short lived app short lived pods.
And and so you basically have to capture
all this data, give context to it, ship
it with resilience to an output of your
choice.
And another challenge here is the formatting. So
another example here, you know, Apache logs, MySQL,
JSON.
Everyone has their own format. These things just
keep on evolving.
It's not never getting any easier.
And so what what the team at at
Treasure Data did was when they were building
their analytics service, they said, hey. We need
some way to make sure folks can get
their data into our platform.
And so they actually built a a Fluentd.
And so Fluentd takes
many sources,
whatever those data sources are,
and then is able to route them to
many end destinations.
And so the project actually got started
June 2011. So this year, Fluentd actually turns
10.
So you can even see that these projects
are are, you know, predating
kind of the container era or even, you
know, Kubernetes being open sourced in 2035.
So they were built to solve big data
problems initially,
and, you know, the natural evolution started moving
them towards, hey. Solving cloud native problems where
you're sending data to
highly available cloud environments. You're sending data from
bare metal to
highly available
private cloud environments.
We've, you know, been part of the CNCF
as a project since 2016.
We graduated in 2019.
So graduation is just a a bit of
a status that's given to projects that have
very broad adoption, lots of users, lots of
committers, maintainers,
and, you know, you can see here that
the the adoption's been pretty awesome. You have
folks at Azure, Google Stackdriver, which I believe
now is Google Cloud operations,
Pivotal, Red Hat OpenShift, and these are just
just a few of them.
Eduardo was talking a little bit about Fluentd,
and and what we saw trending with Fluentd
was
that it was written in in Ruby, and,
you know, it it didn't have as heavy
performance as we wanted, and we saw a
growth in IoT type use cases.
So embedded environments
or container environments,
you have super lightweight,
very
constrained resources.
How do you do the same level of
data collection
resiliency
on those environments? And so we actually built
this Fluent Bit project.
It's completely written in c.
It's now one of the preferred solutions for
cloud environments because, I think, similar to an
embedded environment,
while something lightweight, something already packaged, has all
the plug ins ready to go, has all
the resilience.
And, of course, both of these projects are,
you know, Apache license v two. They're all
part of the CNCF.
So they're, you know, free to download, free
to use,
and and you're something you can get started
with immediately.
Now just to kinda give some use cases,
like, what am I gonna actually use Fluentd
and Fluent Bit for?
Some of the really popular use cases,
of course, are centralizing your logs from Kubernetes.
But some of the more advanced use cases,
like reducing cost,
you know, some of the back ends that
you might be sending data to can be
pretty expensive. Right? They charge per gig, and
you you probably don't need to collect every
single log message, especially if it's like a
debug log. So you can filter that data
out.
You can enrich data. So we think about
reducing cost and and improving developer utilization,
not just by taking away data,
but you can actually enrich it. So that
way when you're doing a search, you have
the context or be there of, oh, hey.
This,
you know, trace and this metric and this
log are all related. You can enrich it
with, hey. These are the namespaces for Kubernetes.
This is potentially the server that I'm running
on in bare metal, which is in this
data center and this GeoIP.
Formatting,
so make making sure that you have the
ability to format any arbitrary log
so that way it's easier to be processed
and analyzed and visualized,
redacted,
anonymized.
This is another big use case where you're
collecting all this data.
And I think, you know, the past ten
years have been all about
big data, getting everything
into a single place. The next ten years
are really about, I have all this data
in a place,
but now we have things like privacy concerns.
We have aspects like, hey. What if someone
gets into my data? They can now access
all my records. So how do we help
remove sensitive data before it even hits the
analytics end? Do it all on prem. Do
it while you're collecting the data so no
one ever sees it.
And then neutrality.
So this is another a big use case
is you as a as a
user might be evolving. Right? You might be
using Elasticsearch one day. You wanna try low
key the other day,
then you wanna switch to a SaaS the
other day.
How do you make sure that you're not
dependent on a single vendor? You know, what
cloud native computing foundation allows us to do
is be very,
very vendor neutral and then have all these
outputs so you can quickly switch and say,
let me try sending my data to both
Splunk and Elastic. And, I can
compare those two with the same set of
data. How does it actually go and switch
if, you know, I I I so deem
it to be a better experience or whatnot?
So, yeah, that's some of the use cases,
and and I think it's worthwhile to just
walk through, like, how does it actually work.
So I'll pass it off to Eduardo to
talk a little bit about kinda logging in
in Kubernetes and that workflow there.
Yeah. The the logging in Kubernetes
is quite different from normal applications.
Right? In a normal application or
bare metal servers,
you just have your application
spawn in the logs through the file system
or nowadays through system systemd.
That anyways, both modes ended up in the
in the file system.
But in the container space,
they tried to come up with this new
approach where
actually, it comes from the very old days
where every system has its own console. Right?
And when you can debug the the server,
you can debug the hardware when you are
getting information from the hardware or the service
that are running. Right? Actually, you can do
that with Linux nowadays. Right? You can attach
to a serial interface
and see how the the kernel is booting.
Not in the, but you can do it
with a normal system.
But in containers, they said, yeah. If we
have an application that needs to trigger messages
for logging information or even metrics inside the
logs, right, which is a very common approach
to
they said, okay. We're going to run this
and ship all the information from the standard
output or to the standard error interface,
which is, the the common the common channels
for an application.
So when this application in Kubernetes runs in
a container,
the container
runtime,
right, it could be Docker or Cree or
any other of the same family. What it
does, it traps the output from
from this application.
And what it does, it will encapsulate this
and put this in a insight
another kind of message which has more context.
Right? Because it has a stream, it has
the timestamp, and so on. And this log
file ended up in the file system.
So every every container deployed in Kubernetes, it's
inside a pod, and a pod can have
multiple containers. So just imagine that in your
environment, you have a a few couple of
nodes. Your application has replicas. Maybe your application's
running different places.
They're storing the logs in different ways, and
and you need to correlate all this information.
So the workflow is like the application writes
the information to the standard outputs, standard error
interfaces. This is trapped by the container,
and this is stored
usually in the file system, right, directly as
a JSON file.
And then what it does is not just
you don't get just a message that you
used to have, but also you get more
notion about the stream and the timestamp.
But as I said, what about if you're
running in a different kind of notes distributed
environment?
You're missing some information in the log, like
what is the host name, port name, the
container name, the port ID.
Because at the end of the day, what
you want to do is data analysis. But
if you're not able to correlate your data,
right, it's really hard to understand how your
application is behaving
or try to find any kind of anomaly.
So any logging processor needs to correlate
log in local information
but also metadata.
If you look carefully how this how this
works from a login perspective, it means that
you have to collect the information from the
file system. It doesn't matter what kind of
it's a source of data.
You have to collect this data. You have
to parse this data.
Right? Maybe you need to filter out or
enrich your data, and then you can send
your data out to a final storage, which
could be a cloud provider or your own
local
database,
like a MySQL
or Lucky or any kind of
other storage type. And this
workflow
is called which is the pipeline. Right? And
Fluentd and Fluent Bit implement that pipeline.
Now the simple message that started like,
for example, an access log for Apache or
NGINX gets some a little bit of metadata.
But in Kubernetes,
actually, when we correlate all the information together,
your simple look measure gets something like this.
Right? Where you have the Kubernetes entries with
botnet, message for the ID,
information about the host, and and so on.
So all this correlation is is a bit
complex, but give you the full access to
the context.
And when you deploy a a logging agent,
could be Fluentd or Fluentd,
it runs as a demo set. A demo
set is a pod that runs on every
node of your node sort of your cluster.
So what it does is to read the
local file system logs from the containers,
and as soon as it is retrieving the
data, it goes to the API server. If
you can switch to the next slide, please.
Yeah. And so it can correlate all the
missing parts like labels or annotations
or any custom information.
And then the log processor is just ready
to ship the data out
to the world or your local file system
so you can perform a data analysis.
The thing is that Fluentd
and Fluent Bit has been around for a
while. I would say that the first class
citizen for
log management
and stability,
but also not just logs. Also, I would
say that at least Fluent Bit also is
playing a a good role now integrating metrics
as as part of the agent.
And one of the important things when when
when running an agent,
this we we have work we work very
close with cloud providers and talking with from
a community perspective, with Google, with Microsoft, with
AWS.
It's like, at the end of the day,
for example, end users or, like, customers,
right, they say, yes. I want to deploy
my applications,
but I want that the logging layer
be very cheap in terms of CPU processing
and memory.
So
as Anurag said, yeah, we have Fluentd. It's
widely deployed,
and we started working for the last five,
six years on trying to come up with
that lightweight solution.
I would say that nowadays, Fluentd is positioned
like at the default for Kubernetes clusters
at a low cost performance, of course.
Yeah. So that's a a bit of an
overview
on
Fluentd, Fluent Bit, some of the use cases,
how you can actually apply it to Kubernetes.
But, yeah,
it's a a little bit of an overview.
Hope it helps.
It does. I think
I mean, I had a bunch of questions
I was gonna ask, and I think you
probably got most of them there in that
presentation. So that's that's pretty well done.
It was a good sales pitch. Yeah. Definitely.
Yeah. You know, I mean, one of those
things I think that is easy for maybe
some people to take for granted is that
the job of the log collector maybe is
rather simple. And I think you did a
really good job of doing well actually in
certain environments it is definitely not.
I think it's always important for people to
understand what actually happens to the log data
when they don't run NSN in their cluster
to centralize it, know and that was all
covered as well. I think that was a
really good overview of the kind of the
way things are working and and where the
fluent to fluent projects can kinda come in
and augment and help and even talking about
the enrichment of the data I think is
extremely valuable too and of course the plugins
were reducing costs. Lots of great info on
those slides top job.
I guess one of the things we could
discuss is just,
know, is there any semantics heuristic rules for
when anyone should pick Fluentd over Fluent Bit,
Fluent Bit over Fluentd, you know, I noticed
certainly
CPU and memory constraints that Fluentd is gonna
be more applicable to at least in certain
environments but does that mean that I shouldn't
use it and environments where that isn't a
constraint? Is there any
what's your expertise there?
Yeah.
Really good question.
Very sure.
Okay. Great. Yeah.
So so I
think one of the big things with with
Fluentd and Fluent Bit is, you know, Fluentd
does have
a much longer history, which lends itself to
a ton of more plug ins. So if
you look at the number of plug ins
that Fluentd has,
is it worth a thousand. Right? It's like,
you can go find a plug in for
something,
you know, as enterprise via Snowflake,
and you can find
plug ins for, you know,
Jill's app server that's running locally or something.
So you have just this wide variety of
plug ins, and one of the the things
we try to do with Fluent Bit was
learning
around this expanse of the plugin ecosystem.
How do you make a really good set
of almost official plugins that come with the
bundle itself?
And so what a lot of folks have
done is with these log collectors, we we
allow you to run them in what's called
a forward
and aggregator pattern.
And this means I'm gonna take the lightest
weight agent, and all it's gonna do is
forward data. It's gonna collect all the data,
make sure it's resilient, and fire it off
to something to do more processing on.
And then that aggregator pattern, which has traditionally
been Fluentd,
is something that you're running almost like a
dedicated server for. It consumes a lot more
resources,
but at the same time, is outputting tons
and tons of volume. So, you know, we
have users that are outputting, a petabyte per
day,
and they're using this forward aggregator
plan because the nice thing that Fluent Bit
and Fluentd have is they share this protocol
of sending raw message pack, which is like
a serialized JSON,
and you can fire that data with Fluent
Bit as a forwarder, Fluentd as an aggregator,
and then route it to, like, say, s
three or Elasticsearch
or wherever.
Now the choice
these days is is
we're also making it applicable so Fluent Bit
could be used as an aggregator as well.
So now instead of just using Fluent Bit
on the forwarder node, you can choose Fluent
Bit as an aggregator.
And one of the reasons why
folks have been hesitant is, okay, the plug
ins might not be as robust as what
Fluentd offers and then multiprocess.
So, actually, really cool is this next release
that we're we're preparing.
We're we're allowing for multiprocess, multithreading. I will
flip it.
So the yeah. The roles are definitely
bit mesh. So there's know, one's a project,
one's a subproject.
But, you know, we're we are making sure
that you can choose whichever one.
And we're, of course, making sure Fluent Bit
is using the lowest amount of resources
and has its kind of centralized plug in
system.
So Nice. I hadn't actually considered that. It
was that it was that it wasn't a
question of which one to use, but actually
use them in a combination to set the
environment that you're trying to work with. That
makes a lot of sense.
Alright. Shall shall we get started? Shall we?
Let's do it. Yeah. Let's Yeah. And and
install.
Alright. Well, I have the the website here.
I think we've covered all of the abouts.
So we're just gonna go straight I guess
to
the documentation.
Now will we start with Fluentd? Will we
start with Fluentbet? Do you have a preference?
Let's start with Fluentd and then Fluent Bit
has some some pretty pretty cool advanced use
cases and we can kinda finish off with
those, but fluent let's do Fluentd to start.
Yep. Alright.
I'll go straight to the installation
and we can see we got options for
deviance, MSI, source, Ruby gems, etcetera. Is there
a
Kubernetes
option?
So with Kubernetes, you can do a deployment
from our helm charts.
So that's that's probably the easiest way to
to do Kubernetes.
I believe there should be a Kubernetes
doc in there as well. Let's see.
There's a
search on the top right. I won't know
the exact
Alright. Let's
try that.
Yeah. Perfect.
There we go. Nice.
So let's see. What if we got set
up in advance? Now one of the things
I like to do in this show is,
well, nothing upfront. I like it to be
quite open and transparent.
Nobody wants to watch me spin up a
Kubernetes cluster and I've gone ahead and just
provision some elastic search and combine. I know
it's very uninteresting but I suspect that when
we start collecting logs, actually wanna be able
to put them somewhere. So I just made
a little bit of an assumption there. Now
we can scroll down here
and
the
deployment option for Fluentd then as a daemon
set, that comes back to I guess what
you had on your slides like the container
runtime
is writing logs already to the host. So
we need to have something running on each
of the nodes to be able to collect
that.
Exactly.
Yep.
Okay. So
I think it wants me to clone.
Yeah. So you can you can clone this.
You might also just be able to go
to that since it's a david set file.
Just kind
of apply it straight from there too.
So is there no configuration
for this? Like
There there is. There is for sure. So
in here
Yeah. I think that in the back route,
Rawkode, and
and the account service.
Yeah. Exactly. So here, what we have is
a bunch of examples of back end. So
in that repo, you saw, like, Elasticsearch.
I think there was Loggly.
I believe there's a couple others. Yeah. Like
GCS, Ray Log. Australia. Access Log. Yeah. Exactly.
Exactly. Yeah. So
if you're if you're a vendor, you know,
and you wanna you wanna put one in
there, we're happy to take contributions.
Yeah.
Alright. I'll assume we maybe want the
daemon set, elastic search, RBAC example.
Yes. Or should I use a Helm chart
or will I just apply this and we'll
cross our fingers? It's yeah. So the Helm
chart essentially takes this daemon set and applies
the daemon set. It applies some service accounts,
the same cluster actually, yeah, this is pretty
much the same exact thing. That was an
even though it just says daemon set, it
includes kinda multiple things. So whichever one
you want there.
Yeah.
Well, I'm feeling brave. So we'll just
alright. So I'm assuming it's maybe gonna be
running in
it's on namespace?
I think I think it's a login login
namespace.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Oh, it's a KubeSystem.
Yep. KubeSystem. Alright. So Mhmm.
Let's have a look and see if it
is running unhappy.
Oh, I just did a dashy anyway. Force
to happen. Yeah.
It might be running. I think the other
thing that we probably need to do is
modify it
for the elastic search. So, like, modify the
the settings and everything. But you'll actually, one
cool thing to see here is,
you know,
sometimes your provider or the the Kubernetes cluster
you have will already have Fluentd and Fluent
Bit running on it as part of its,
like, system logs. So here you can see,
like, Fluent Bit is already in there, but
that's not something we deployed. We just deployed
Fluentd.
Yeah.
Yeah. I got it. Think yeah. JKE provides
us at the box now, which is quite
cool. Mhmm.
Yeah.
Let's get some code editors going.
Create a new file.
Copy, paste.
So what was it you said we potentially
want to be modifying here?
Yes. We wanna modify the,
yeah, the host
as well as the password for the user.
And then depending on the version, so if
you're using
something that has security enabled
or user enabled, we'll wanna modify that too.
You mean from the Elasticsearch site?
Yeah. From the Elasticsearch site. Yeah. I don't
think there's
I I don't think there's any authentication. I
think we should be okay. Alright. So okay.
So then I think with the user and
password, we might be able to just
comment that out. Yeah.
Woah. That should be okay.
Oh, because I haven't saved it with an
extension, so it doesn't know how to comment.
There we go.
Alright. We'll try it. Yeah. I just did
a default helm install for Elastic search.
I guess maybe I could check if that
installs
any authentication
but I think by default it's
it's difficult. So
Okay. Let's apply this over the top.
Wait for it to be happy again.
So the first enhancement is to that we
have to do is, like, rename a brand
document that is not just a demo set,
so it's ready to go.
Yes.
So now that I've changed the elastic search
config map, where I think I'm gonna have
to just kill all those pods, right, and
force it to reload the configuration?
I think I think it's probably doing it
one by one. So it still looks like
it's terminating p r five.
Yeah. And then it looks like it restarted.
Alright. That'll probably terminate another one. Yeah. Oh,
it's doing it in a slow way. I
I prefer the the gung ho approach. I
would've just have deleted the Me too.
Yeah.
But but what we should be able to
see is in that one running container is
we can check
if we do a cube CTL logs on
that,
see if it's running,
maybe make sure it's not, like, outputting any
errors in case of, like, some
security or anything. Okay. Looks like it's following
the tails.
Yeah. It's following the files.
Yeah. That that looks happy to me. I
mean, I don't I don't see an error.
Does that mean that it's flushed into Elasticsearch
and everything's happy?
Fingers
crossed. Yeah. May like, maybe let's check out
Kibana, to be honest.
Alright. So let's set a quick port forward.
Five six zero one.
There
we go.
Let's see.
This is different.
Yeah. So I think we'll go to create
an index pattern first,
if I remember correctly.
If you go all the way down
to stack management.
There you go.
The index
sorry. Index
patterns.
Gotcha. And
I believe the default uses the Logstash pattern.
So if you do a Logstash dash star,
we'll define that as the pod pattern.
Yeah. Perfect. Yeah. And we can see there's
there's a new index there, 1.15,
which I'm going to assume is the
It's the index here today.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So we can click next.
Alright. I'll I'll just dismiss this. My data
is not secure. Warning.
Oh, no.
I'll send the timestamp field as timestamp.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And
Yep.
So that means we select it.
Should have data. And we
exactly. Go to discover
And
crossing all our fingers here. There
we go. Yeah.
So
Nice. That was a straightforward.
That Used to be more complex years ago.
That is the easiest installation I have done
in this show so far, and it wasn't
gonna help chat. So that's a bonus for
me. Yeah.
Yeah. It's the the thing is you did
have security on. Otherwise, we have to go
get the cert and then have to add
the cert.
But
Yeah. That's it's
it's meant to be very simple. Right? Get
get started, ship the logs,
enrich the logs. So even if if you
zoom in to one of them, you'll see,
like, you have Docker container ID, you have
Kubernetes container name.
All of that is available to you.
Oh, yes. Because this information won't actually be
in the log outputs of each of the
applications running on my cluster. This is something
that Fluentd is going, hey. We're inside a
Kubernetes
environment. We should start to enrich this log
of all of these details. Exactly.
Exactly. It it'll enrich it, cache that result,
and then just basically enrich every log that
comes in.
Excellent.
So
with one command
it's running. We have our logs. We are
thrown to elastic. We visualize it for Kibana.
Is that us done? Are we going home
early?
So so
yeah. I mean, I mean, we really could.
But the the next step that folks could
take afterwards is like, okay. Hey. I wanna
filter out
some logs. I wanna redact some logs. I
want to
potentially
send data to Elasticsearch,
and I wanna send it to Amazon s
three or
a large data warehouse. Right? So these are,
like, kind of the next steps
in login journeys where
you're collecting everything.
That's awesome. This might be too much data,
though. And now you're like, okay. How do
I filter it out? How do I redact
it? How do I anonymize it? How do
I send it to a cheaper data storage
if I need to?
So, yeah, there's, like, a ton of ton
of options that that you can do with
once once it's all all set and and
ready to go.
Alright. So so we try and and filter
this data down a little bit, see if
we can reduce the throughput?
Sure. Yeah.
Alright.
Or
what you know, what we could do
is let's let's switch to Fluent Bit and
then do some of that stuff there because
there's some really cool capabilities we've been working
on in Fluent Bit with
with the processing
that I I think would be would be
really cool to to showcase here. We could
use the same Elasticsearch
endpoint as well.
Yeah. Sure. So I guess I just gotta
come back to here.
Let's see if I can work this out.
Oh, no. That was the
wrong URL.
So is the manifest in here or is
it a different
report? It's gonna be a different
Sorry. I didn't catch that.
Oh, sorry. Yeah. Just go to the Fluent
Bit website,
and you can hit the documentation.
So we have documentation on how to deploy
from the daemon set file, right, using the
raw files.
But also,
I would say, to be honest, most of
people are using the official hand charts.
Well, there are two hand charts. Right? The
old stable that are being deprecated by the
HAM project and
and and the ones that we have.
So if you go to installation
on the left menu,
you will find the Kubernetes option.
Alright.
So we have the
ability to create all the manifests.
We got the elastic search option and we
have a helm chart. So a little bit
of flexibility there. Let's try the helm one
then. Yeah.
We'll add the repository
and
I guess we'll maybe need to tweak this
values fail a little bit. Right?
Ex exactly. Yeah. So we wanna tweak the
values dot yaml just a bit.
So I think let's see. In the value
section,
we have, yeah, a a match
of
Let's see. Alright.
So here's the config.
I guess the end pitch is already configured
for Kubernetes. Yeah. I can see some stuff
here. Exactly.
Then we have the Kubernetes filter,
and then we have the outputs here. So
I think we just changed the host,
and it will automatically assume port 9,200.
I think it was actually the service name,
wasn't it? I don't think I need to
change it.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Oh, no. I think different
namespace.
Oh, okay. Yep.
Assuming we don't install I don't know if
the default namespace on this will go to
whatever the helm context is. So maybe it
won't be done. Oh, what what version of
Kubernetes is this, by the way? I believe
it's one seventeen.
Okay. Is that the one Because one seventeen
comes with Fluent Bit on GTE.
That's a new version.
So the the one thing I was thinking
of is
so the actually, this change from Docker to
CRI as the default
is a different format of log, of course.
And so we we do have all the
CRI parts of this within Fluent Bit out
of the box as well and Fluentd.
But, yeah, just to you know, for folks
who are saying, okay. I wanna try this
on my
my
Kubernetes cluster. If you're using one of the,
you know, bleeding edge versions that doesn't have
Docker, just your right, just make sure that
that's enabled by default if you're using the
CRI parser.
Yeah. I think in my conversations, I've been
having with people over the the last six
months. A lot of people are now starting
to push towards running container d by default.
So I think that's useful information for folks.
Alright.
So we're gonna provide our own values file,
although I don't think we've actually changed anything
yet. So this is technical.
Just the defaults, but I'm sure we'll be
making a few changes in a moment. So
let's give that a second.
Alright.
And I think another difference with the default
config of Fluent Bit is instead of using
Logstash
format, it uses Fluent Bit as the index
name, if I am correct.
So I guess if we go to that
index screen where we were just previously on,
we should maybe see a different pattern show
up?
Correct. Yeah.
I I think that the Logstash format was
enabled.
Oh, was The configuration that we just saw.
Yeah. I think that was enabled. Yeah. That
you can configure that. Right? Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Launch that. Launch that. That
from at all.
Can I just set it to off? Yeah.
Actually, in the configuration, you can add your
own prefix if you want so you can
separate
or create a new kind of a index.
So I'm curious, like,
what you mentioned there was that there's a
Fluent Bit syntax
or is that just a prefix?
Prefix. Yeah. You can set it. You can
set it up.
Okay. So do I want Logstash format on
or off?
Let's do off. Let it on.
Off.
Alright. Let's let's turn it on then, and
then we'll change the prefix to Fluent Bit.
Yeah. Let's see what happens. I
never tried those, I think.
Yeah.
I think I I usually do mill logs
dash format and then have the index name
as, like, Fluent Bit so I can easily
identify it.
So I I'm I'm confused. So let's let's
break down this output format a little bit.
Right? We have two outputs here. There's one
that's matched on cube.star
and one matching on host.star.
Can you tell me what the difference between
these two is?
Yeah. Actually Yeah. So in
I think it might be easy to
visualize this. So if we actually have a
a visualizer
if you wanna try that out, config visualizer.
So if you copy copy
this file real quick
and then go to the URL
config,httpsconfig.calypdia,caly.
Sorry. Can you say that again? Yes. Calyptia.perfect,.com.
Yeah. Let me just go to that.
And then throw in that configuration.
Cool.
Okay.
So in this configuration,
we are taking the tail. We're we're reading
all of the
Kubernetes
logs.
We're enriching all those logs with Kubernetes
filter that we saw before, and then we
match that to Elasticsearch.
And then the bottom visualization
is we're actually also reading from system d
as an input and also sending that to
Elasticsearch,
but it has a different
match. So the way that Fluentd and Fluent
Bit work is there's a a nice tagging
system.
So you can kinda build separate pipelines
throughout the entire system.
And within this, we're we basically define two
pipelines. We have a pipeline of cube dot
star.
So it grabs all the Kubernetes logs, enriches
them, sends it to Elasticsearch,
and then we also have the system d.
So at any time, if we, say, want
to modify one of the pipelines,
we wanna output to a different
output, like, say, Loki or
Splunk or something like that, we could just
say output Splunk match cube dot star.
And so that visualization
would
when you would update so that you're taking
all your Kubernetes logs and you're sending it
to two destinations.
Alright. Nice.
This is a cool tool.
This isn't
who are Calypdia?
Yeah. So it's a it's a kind of
brand new brand new thing that that we're
part of that's
kinda behind Fluent Bit and and Fluentd. So
it's free to use. So just just released
it earlier this week. But,
yeah, it's it's nice for these configurations, right,
when you're
basically trying to figure out how to, you
know, go about them, how to use them,
and and whatnot. Yeah. That's a nice touch
as well on the right where when I
click on each of these nodes, it has
documentation
for each of them on the right. I
quite like that. Very cool. Yeah.
Okay. So based on that then
and I understand
this as our system d journal d logs,
this is the container log files from the
runtime.
Do we only need to prefix on this
the host logs or do we wanna log
prefix on this one too?
Let's do log prefix on both. Yeah.
Okay.
So we'll call this bet node
and bet cube.
Is that alright?
Yeah.
Okay. So let's
redeploy this over the top.
Oh, upgrade.
And I believe default is it'll do a
rolling, so it will do the same. Terminate
one.
And and one thing you might notice is
when you terminate Fluentd
and Fluent Bit is they
actually, I will wait to finish consuming all
the records they have in their buffer
so that way you don't lose any information
either.
Very cool. Yeah.
So let's go back over to
here,
I believe.
Oh, I've killed the port forward doesn't I?
There we go.
Give that a wee moment.
So now that we've got one or two
of those fluent bits rotated,
we should hopefully see
a couple of new entries on this page.
Yeah. One thing interesting thing in the configuration,
for example, I think that was the main
difference between
how
routing works in Fluentd and Fluent Bit.
Just when we wait for this. It's like,
you know, we have two destinations.
Right? In Fluentd, if you want to have
two destinations for the same records,
it it for example, if you have one
region in two destinations,
what you do in the output is to
copy the content for diff for two destinations.
The difference in the configuration of Fluent Bit
that you can say, I have this information
go to two places, but there's not a
copy.
So you don't copy the data internally.
So we just can optimize
on on memory and performance.
And we we found cases that say, hey.
I have 32 outputs.
Actually, for Fluent Bit. And they say, yeah.
We are hitting a limit. Right? And and
that's really interesting. So why somebody would have
32 outputs?
Right? So 32 destinations.
And, actually, what we're doing is, like, to
accommodate the the same Elasticsearch
cluster with different setups.
Now that kind of things will be a
bit more complex in Fluentd for that special
case because you will need to copy the
same data
to 32
places. Right? And here, we just can have
one reference.
I think that you can start with now
with the index pattern name with Bit Cube.
Yes.
There's the data.
That's interesting.
Yeah. I think it's, like, combined a
log
logstash
time stamp with the with maybe potential other
timestamps that are in the log. I'd use
the at timestamp to be safe. Yeah. You
said that. That that's a better one. Okay.
And do we want to set up the
the best host, or are just interested in
the Kubernetes one for now?
Let's do Bit host too. Yeah. Okay. K.
Oh, Bit Node. My bad.
Oh, yeah. Bit Node. Sorry.
Alright. Discover.
So now we have Fluentd collecting the logs,
Fluent back collecting the logs,
and it's now all gonna show up here,
I think.
So do we just change this to
the cube?
Exactly.
And then we cross our fingers
and boom. Yeah. There it is.
So
nothing
other than obviously using a completely different binary,
written in a completely different language
with a different deployment mechanism.
This is still very similar. Right? This is
still enriching
all of my log data the same way
that Fluentd was. Exactly.
Exactly. Okay.
So why don't we try and filter this
down then?
What's what's the first one?
So we gotta decide a bit what we
want to filter out
is
but if we take a look at the
log,
there's
a couple of fields that seem,
you know, may maybe a little voluminous that
we don't need.
So if we look at, say,
you know, the container hash maybe,
that might be something we just remove.
Or we could even say,
okay. Let's filter that only send the messages
that are gets, not post. You know, I
don't I don't care about my post messages.
I only wanna
consume my get
images or sorry. My get messages.
So that's messages that have this tag of
request method post.
Exactly.
Exactly. So we could we could use that
as a filter.
Okay. So does that mean I have to
modify my home config?
Correct. Yep. So you'll modify
this.
So the the way that Fluent Bit configuration
works is you have your inputs, you have
your filters, and then your outputs.
And then if you're also, like, ingesting logs,
you have parsers.
So what we'll do here is we will
actually just create another filter
underneath this Kubernetes filter.
So, yeah, same format filter. Perfect.
We're going to use the GREP
filter. Great. And so the GREP filter basically
will
take in
all of the messages,
and it will reduce it down only to
the ones that, as GREP does, match a
particular regex.
Now I am gonna be a little
old and and not remember the exact prep
config, so might need to go to the
prep docs.
Alright. So let's see.
Configuring
let's just search. Right? Pipeline in in the
pipeline?
Oh, you can do yeah. Type Grip.
Type
Grip. You can type grip in the search.
Ah, there we go. Yeah. A bit meta.
Right? You're grepping.
You're searching for grip.
One feature of the grip filter is that
you can match specific patterns or you can
exclude
content from
that matches a pattern.
Right? So you can make the you can
work from two ways.
Yeah. Go well with that with that example.
That's fine.
Perfect. Yeah. So match start means it's gonna
look at every single incoming message
that's coming in. And then what we're going
to do is the the way that this
is set up is you have regex,
the key name of the log,
and then the content or the regex regular
expression.
So in this key name, we're going to
use that
yeah. Exactly.
And then here, we'll just use regex of
post. Perfect.
Note that the key name,
it it works in a in a different
way. So in Fluent Bit, there's a concept
of record accessor.
Because if you look at, for example, how
the payloads of Kubernetes are in the logs,
right, they have many nested fields.
And sometimes you want to match a specific
pattern
that is not in the first label.
So the way that it works is like,
for example, go to the configuration,
put the US dollar sign
at the beginning.
Okay? And then so that means I'm going
to access
the content of the
rec key. Right? And then instead of that
dot
Yeah. Or unless how how is the key
what is the key name that was created?
Is request an an asset field called method,
or it was request dot method? Request dot
method. Request dot method.
Oh, can you show the JSON file? If
you could scroll up, there's the JSON version.
That's really important to to clarify.
Yeah.
Scroll down.
Oh, okay. Okay. Method
is
a nested field
of request. Right? It's not just one label.
You got two labels.
Okay.
Okay. Go back to the configuration.
Request squares a brace.
Remove the dot and use square brace, single
quote
for method. Yeah. That's it. And if you
have more nested skills, you can add more
square braces to access the sub content.
So so to to give a a bit
of a a summary here. So if in
Kibana,
if we go back to viewing Kibana,
the record that we actually get is a
bunch of nested JSON. The nice thing is
when we go to actually, like, view the
column and table side, Kibana actually will say,
hey. Let's take those nested fields and shorten
it so it shows request dot method.
So when we are going to access
the record,
we're not accessing the flattened
request
dot method. We actually have to use the
Fluent Bit configuration to say, hey. You need
to access this this record and the sub
properties of that record
instead of just rec dot method.
So if that makes I hope that makes
sense. Yeah. Yeah. I think I've got that.
Yeah.
Awesome. Awesome.
And this syntax is is is quite familiar.
So, you know Right.
Yeah. I'm just gonna apply this and let's
see what happens. Let's see. Yeah.
We better not get any gets in the
method.
Yeah. I guess one thing is Sorry. I
didn't go. Oh,
I was just gonna say I as it
rolls out, it will probably apply individually.
So we might see some,
you know, like, other ones that are capturing
all the logs still.
But hopefully, you know, within once the year
all rolled out, we should only see posts.
Okay. And
let's assume I wanted to filter something else.
Say, maybe I don't actually want anything from
the cube system namespace.
Now
if I just add a new filter, do
these all work independently?
Are they all,
you know, like, Andy together?
How do the filters work when there's more
than one?
So it's all top to bottom and all
ended together. And so because you're using a
match star, actually, both system d and your
tail will run through this filter
while everything else will only run through like,
your Kubernetes data only runs through the Kubernetes
filter.
So this we if we wanna be very
specific that it only runs on the Kubernetes
side, we'll we can change the match to
cube dot star and kinda keep it as
part of that one pipeline.
Or if we wanna have everything run through
this filter, we can we can do that
with the match star as well.
Okay. You can try to visualize that configuration
to explain the concept.
Yeah. Yeah. So if you wanna again.
Okay.
So
because You can copy everything. Yeah. It will
strip down everything that doesn't
it's not necessary.
Alright. Okay. Alright. Let's go here. I was
just worried about those nested
YAML keys,
but let's see what happens.
If you click, I gotta click back. Yeah.
And then there, you can delete, paste. Let's
see. There. Perfect.
Okay. So this one is a little different.
Right? So everything
that's coming from the tail goes into Kubernetes.
But then from
system d,
we now have a new filter that's part
of the pipeline,
which is the scrap filter.
And so all of those logs will also
be matched and say, okay. If I find
in the request
dot method,
there is a post. I will only filter
for those results.
The the likelihood here is, though, that the
system d probably doesn't even have request dot
method,
so it might not be able to capture
or include any of those logs.
So
to to kinda fix it, we could make
it so that GREP only applies to Kubernetes,
or we could even put, you know, like,
hey. That's fine. We're only gonna look for
the GREPs that do match this.
Okay.
Let me try something.
Yeah. Gonna copy and paste this.
Just call this random. I just wanna visualize
it and make sure I understand that correctly.
Mhmm.
So
copy from here.
Yeah. So kinda got this
workflow,
this chain of groups are kind of awesome.
Perfect. Yep.
So now that we've given that a few
minutes, if we come back to here
and
I guess just refresh.
Do do we apply it? Do we apply
the new config?
We did. Right? Yeah. We did.
Oh, okay. Cool. Then we just gotta port
forward Kibana then. Oh, yes.
Let's refresh.
I'll just set that. So we applied that
roughly 25. Assume it took a few minutes
then. Let's just drop this down to see.
The last two minutes.
Update.
And we shouldn't see any
in theory, shouldn't see any request dot posts.
Only we should only see request dot post.
Yeah. Oh, we should only see request dot
post. Alright. Okay. Oh, well. Yeah.
There's one there. So Because because we have
a rejects rule, but you can regret if
you put instead of rejects, you put exclude,
you will get the opposite. Right?
Yeah.
Just just get they get the request.
Yeah. So post post post post.
I won't go through them all. Let's let's
trust it. I'm assuming they're all false.
Another
kinda way we can make sure it worked
is if you look at the data volume,
we can see that's kind of reduced a
decent amount too. So instead of, like, 20
records, we're now seeing, like, two or three.
So that's a it's not the most accurate
way, of course, but it's another way to
check.
Excellent. That was relatively painless.
Great.
Where should we add next?
Next, let's do some stream processing.
I mean, this sounds quite scary, but I'll
let's do it. Yeah. Let's make a a
small intro before Anurag jumps into the demo.
The thing is that we always think that
a Fluentd as a separate of Fluentd
needs to go beyond what is loading. Right?
Is I I would say that is yeah.
It will take you two, like, three years
to write an agent that just ship logs
from one place to the other.
But I think that when people start implementing
filters
or trying to do enrichment,
right, at the end of the day, they
are trying to do some processing of the
data. Actually, what you do, right, applies some
filters that is data processing.
But we wanted to go beyond that and
say, hey. Why we cannot sense that all
the data is flowing through Fluent Bit?
Why we cannot implement a stream an official
stream processing agent?
Like,
the data is flowing. Yeah. What about if
we provide the ability to query the data
in memory while it's flowing
using SQL language?
But without database,
without tables,
without indexing.
Right? This is just very Fluent Bit, no
database or anything extra.
And we found very interesting
use cases.
Some of them were like some people said,
yeah. I don't have a filter to
to do a, b, and c. But using
the stream processor,
running a SQL query, I was able to
recompose my records,
create a new stream of data,
tag that data, and send those results to
a different endpoint.
And then people say, hey. We can do
alerting. We can do machine learning. We cannot
we can do many kind of things.
And in general so we extended the pipeline
a little bit.
So we have input filters,
output, and now we have input filters,
optional stream processing,
and outputs,
right, where you can do a lot of
magic with the data that that is flowing.
If you are familiar with Kafka
and KSQL,
maybe you'll find that this is really similar
concept but applied to to the agent, to
the login. And, actually, this sounds very familiar
to everything that people is talking about
each stream processing. Right? Do a stream processing
where the data is being generated
and not just after being aggregated.
And one interesting use case is like, I
have my application. My application is recording,
I don't know, credit card transactions.
Right? And how do you detect a double
charge?
Right? Normally,
you just send all your information to a
database. You do the analysis.
But that process, since you're running at scale,
can take a couple of minutes because all
your data needs to be indexed. And we
just saw in a in a short demo
that it take a couple of seconds
to get some small amount of results.
So what about if we would have the
option to detect double charges in milliseconds?
And as soon as that happens,
trigger an alert to Slack, custom HTTP endpoint,
or or whatever you need to do in
order to take some action on that. And
and and we have some some demos applied
to stream processes, so please go ahead and
show what we have
working.
This has been around for more than a
year, I think.
Very exciting. All
of the Fluent Bit's that you've installed on
your Kubernetes
all have stream processing capabilities.
So you can add it there as well
just to give a kind of a you
know, I can go ahead and share my
screen. We can do it on this one
if if you're confident. You know?
Let's go for it. Yeah. Why not? Let's
let's try it.
It'll be a little bit more configuration,
but I I think we can do it.
So let's go to first the values side,
the the YAML
that you have in the Helm chart.
Okay.
So what we have to modify in this
YAML is
two things. We have to go
all the way to the top and
include a new file. So
right now, it's only been including
the
main configuration
and the parsers.
So there should be a section.
Let's see.
That config map.
Maybe it's a little above.
Let me look at the line on my
side.
Ah, there it is. Yep. So if you
go down where it says service
and parsers file, it says parsers.com.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Got it.
Yeah. Perfect. Okay. So in this case,
what we're going to do is add a
new
line there.
Let me just grab the configuration of that
line,
and it is going to be
oops.
Is streams streams.
Yeah. Streams_filestreams.com.
Like so?
So we'll delete the first section where it
says parsers file, and it'll just be streams
file instead.
Oh, sorry.
Gotcha. The in that line. Yeah. So the
parameter is called streams file. Exactly. And then
the
value streams.com.
Okay. Perfect. So now we've said, okay. Let's
look for the streams.com
file.
And now what we need to add in
this configuration
is a
streams.com
file.
So let's copy the parsers.com
configuration.
If you go all the way to the
bottom
yeah. So we have custom parsers.
And
in here, what we're gonna do is add
let me see.
Oh, actually, now that I'm thinking because the
I've actually never done stream processing within this
Helm chart.
This is a it's a it's a new
wondrous thing that we're we're trying for the
first time. What do I think we can
do? Let's see. I'm gonna look at the
values side on my
laptop here
because I just wanna know what what we
would add within the,
yeah, within the values file. So that way,
we can say, okay. This section right here
is a stream processor job, but we're gonna
add it as streams.com.
See.
Workspace.
I assume there's also documentation
that people can, yeah, introduce Yeah. Machine from
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So is this using Apache Ato or something
else under the hood?
All
implemented within c.
Okay.
I've seen a lot of projects kind of
try to provide and memories and SQL like
languages to stream processing and they I've seen
it as quite common for people to use
Apache Auto with the Parquet format.
I was just curious.
I I think most so the one thing
we wanted was to keep the relative
footprint very, very low.
And, you know, if you're doing very simple
stream processing jobs, you don't want, like
I
know Parquet format's not too large or anything
like that, but how do you just make
it so it's a few lines of configuration
versus
having to install, like, a new application application
or even embed that application in?
Yeah. Configuration, right now, I think that it's
not straightforward.
Right?
But it's something that, yeah, we will be
improve during
this year because we're getting more use cases.
Cases.
And, actually, we're going to extend the stream
process of capabilities.
Right now, for example, we don't support joins,
but we will do it. Right now, we
mostly support key selections,
aggregation windows.
So, yeah, you can do some kind of
analytics now with what we have,
and that's really interesting.
Alright. Definitely. And then
yeah.
And so
and and, for example, what we envision with
the StreamProcessor
is not just for logs but also with
metrics.
Right?
Usually, some agents try to ship all the
metrics that they are collecting,
but sometimes you have sample of metrics every
second. So you don't want to ship all
of that. Right? You just want to ship,
for example, an average number or
do some kind of calculation
every minute.
And
if that calculation
hits some threshold, you can trigger an alert
or maybe not.
So this is, a different pattern of how
to process the data on on the edge.
And, yeah, do this processing, yeah, has a
CPU cost, of course,
But I think that the same cost that
you are having you are having in just
central place
is times higher than do do the same
thing in a distributed fashion.
It's it's it's like a for me, it's
like a new pattern, a new
new way to do
data analytics.
Yeah. Definitely. I I mean, I can already
think of a few use cases where, like,
been able to do that and the stream
and almost real time can get, you know,
operators and developers a really good insight into
how their applications are functioning without waiting on
it going to, you know, some remote back
end and then in their aggregations.
Like, definitely lots of use cases for stream
processing in this context.
How are we feeling about this configs then?
I I I let's try for five minutes
if it doesn't work out. We're gonna go
full demo.
Afraid of the demo, I'm not sure. But
it so the first thing we're gonna actually
have to do is modify the Helm chart's
config map. So the config map is gonna
be
in within this value
slide, we actually have to modify the templates.
So is it not gonna be in the
values YAML, but oh, did you did you
clone the Helm chart or, I guess,
just to the Helm? I am more than
happy to modify the config map live. We
can always just Okay. Eject from Helm. I
have got confidence in this, so let let's
do this. Yeah. That's better. Yeah. Yeah. Let's
do that.
Yeah.
Oh, forgot the
config map. There we go.
Perfect.
Okay. So in this config map,
what we're gonna do is so now we
have this custom parsers.
We're gonna add the custom
custom streams
dot conf.
And,
basically, the configuration for a stream processor
job
looks like a task.
So it will be a bracket It is
and
Stream task.
Stream underscore
task. Okay. Yeah.
Then you just set a name.
Just take man. Right?
Yep. Name. Name.
Yeah.
Name, m a v.
M a n
No. Name. Like, my name is Eduardo. Your
name is David. His name is Andre.
Apologies.
No worries. No. I I think this is
my English. No worries. No. I think I
think it's me and 07:00 on a Friday
night. I think I just
we'll get there. Alright.
So Okay. Let's whatever you want. Like
Let's call it yeah. Perfect. And then the
next line we're gonna do is
exec.
It's right where the name is. Exec.
Create stream.
Oh, sorry. Create space stream.
Perfect. And we're gonna what do we wanna
call this stream? Let's call it Rawkode as
well.
Yeah. And then we're gonna select a tag.
So let's say with
space width,
and then parenthesis
tag
equals,
and let's choose cube dot star.
Perfect. Yeah. You no no space between the
equal.
And
And then put one quotation
between the cube or put the cube dot
star in quotation marks. One quotation marks. Yeah.
Yeah. One thing. We are setting a tag,
so the tag cannot have a wheel card.
It's not a matching rule. So it could
be cube dot Rawkode,
for example.
Perfect. Because the the output of this stream
will be like an input of data in
the pipeline.
Okay.
Awesome. And then let's do as
select.
And what what type of stream process do
we wanna do? Maybe count?
Yeah. Sure. Let's count that many records.
Yeah. And then parenthesis
star perfect as
total count,
and then from
space from
space tag,
and then
let's retype in that cube dot Rawkode.
So dot space bracket. So that like Oh,
I got semicolon.
Sorry.
Single quotes.
So?
Perfect. Oh, actually, sorry. Not semicolon. Just regular
colon.
It's my mistake. And
then after cube dot Rawkode, what we'll do
is define a window to do all this
counting.
And so we'll do window
tumbling
and then space
parenthesis fifteen seconds.
And I think you actually you'll need to
spell out seconds there. So fifteen space seconds.
Fifteen
yeah. Fifteen space second without the final s.
Andre, one question.
In
from the incoming data, you mentioned tag cube
dot Rawkode.
Mhmm. But do we have an incoming tag
with that cube dot Rawkode?
No. So we'll modify the config to just
have a a a a raw code
cube dot Rawkode tag.
So we'll just tag everything as cube dot
Rawkode.
Oh, okay. So the output needs to have
a different text so we avoid that, you
know, the same data flows in the same
process.
Ah, I see. I see what you're saying.
Okay. So let's let's just make the tag
equal to Rawkode, and what we'll add in
the input is a new CPU metric
that will just read in CPU
codes every second. Yeah. Perfect.
Awesome.
Yeah. So I quite I quite like that.
You know, I I was making a few
assumptions as you were kinda telling me what
to type and what I was typing. It
felt just very natural. Like, you know, if
you've worked with any SQL based database or
relational databases, it was that was quite pleasurable.
Awesome.
Yeah. We wanted to make it as SQL
like as possible. Oh, and then just end
with a
excuse me. End with the semicolon.
There we go.
Oh, but my point is that
the stream that we are creating has the
same tag that we are we're we're reading
the data from.
So the outgoing tag needs to be different
if we want to send that results to
a different endpoint.
I see what you're saying. I see what
you're saying. The first tag no. The first
one.
Yeah.
So, basically, the stream is gonna be named
Rawkode. So you can send that Rawkode to
Elasticsearch or Splunk or wherever you want,
and then we're reading from a different
tag. Yep. So if we just call the
tag that what is StreamRawkode and we're pulling
from TagRawkode. So now we have to modify
the log pipeline to add the Rawkode tag.
Right? Okay. Exactly. We'll add stream underscore Rawkode
to the first one too. So execs create
stream, stream underscore Rawkode.
Oh, right. Okay. Gotcha.
Perfect.
Okay. So does that mean we do have
to jump down
to
as do we add tags via the outputs,
or is that something we do with
So in here, let's also add a input
under the Fluent Bit configuration.
Yeah. We'll add a a input of
name CPU,
and then tag,
we will put Rawkode.
Perfect. Okay.
And we'll let we'll also need to delete
our grep because, otherwise, all our data flows
through the grep, and it will be deleted,
or it will only match things that have
that. So let's just delete that grep for
now.
Perfect.
And then we need to also add the
stream processor file
in the service configuration. So if we go
all the way back to the top, under
service,
yeah, streams_filestream.com.
Perfect. And now I believe it's defined above,
but let's just double check
the Yeah. We need a we're we're missing
an s on stream file. It's a streams
file.
Got it. Streams file, and then I think
custom_streams.com
for the filename.
Oh,
custom.
Do you want this to be like that?
Perfect. Perfect. Yeah. So if you There's a
typo there's a typo on the stream task.
In the filename, it say steams, not streams.
Ah, okay. Yeah. And if you go up
maybe 10 lines.
Yeah. The file name is Teams, just add
an r. This is why I never code
alone because I'm dreadful.
So
okay. You got it. Okay. Do we think
this is a valid configuration?
Fingers crossed. Let's go for it.
Oh, we need the output for stream Rawkode.
Oh. We have a matching rule. A match
Yeah. Yeah. We do. Okay. Let's just copy
one of those outputs
and then match Rawkode
stream underscore Rawkode. Excuse me.
And then for Logstash prefix, let's just use
Rawkode.
Perfect. Happy?
I'm very happy.
Alright. So we will have to rotate those
conflict maps ourselves because we didn't use helm.
So delete pod
l. I'm just gonna assume
well, our people will flip back maybe work.
No. I guess not. I have to specify
the the namespace maybe.
I meant the the namespace. We'll just
Choose one of them.
What labels do we have? I mean, I
could have deleted them manually by now of
course, but well
So we have a question. So while I
delete those,
Andres has asked, does
this intermediate aggregated result from the stream persist
during restarts?
How is it stored?
Not now. So
all aggregation window, it doesn't persist.
Right? And this is one of the incursion
that is coming up. Right now, everything runs
in memory.
Yeah. Alright. And, Andreas, may I spot you
the bug in our config? I named both
the outputs ES. Is that a problem?
So the it it's yeah. The name category
is just the type of output. So both
of them are named ES. So there should
be actually three outputs that are ES,
and it's just it it just means, okay.
We're outputting the three Elasticsearches.
Finally, I can type. There we go. Okay.
So we rotated
our Fluent Bit pods.
Hopefully we're not gonna see Crashly back off.
Let's have a wee,
a wee gander.
Wow. They seem happy.
I'm impressed.
I did my best to make them not
work so, you know. Alright.
So let's
report forward to Kibana. Right? And then what
we should
we wanna confirm that that looks okay there?
Is there do we use the Fluentdocs in
line? Let's just let's
just use Kibana. Let's see what we what
we got. We're we're being bold. We're being
bold.
And then we're gonna have to add a
new pattern as well.
Okay. Yeah. So the the okay. The Rawkode
pattern. So let's come back in here,
index patterns.
Nothing yet. Nothing yet.
Let's take a look at the logs of
one of the Fluent Bit bots.
I feel like that's admitting defeat, if I'm
being honest.
Right. Okay.
Log oops. Yeah. Typing
logs
and let's grab this one.
Yeah. See what I see. We gotta fail
to flush chunk. We are getting errors.
And it's the tail to the output.
Oh, it's showing a bunch. Our config map
is wrong?
I think so. Yes. There's something wrong. Oh,
could not initialize the stream processor.
Cannot open Fluent. Oh, it could it could
not read the file.
Custom screen.
Something to conflict map. Yeah.
Alright. Let's exec in.
Do you give me a shell?
No.
No shell. Yeah. No. You should use the
different Fluent Bit image because that one is
distroless,
so it's just a Fluent Bit binary.
Okay.
So do we believe
that that is a table in the file
name or that it's not in the version
of Fluent that we deployed?
Yeah. Let's set it again the conflict map.
Yeah. Let's do it.
So this is the fail that filled. Right?
Streams fail custom underscore streams dot conf.
So earlier, you did say it was just
streams dot conf. Was that not right?
I think it matches. So in your parser,
you have, like, custom parsers defined as data.
Right.
Okay.
So that So the other thing to check
is within your within the custom
dots
this is a bit of an annoying thing,
but is anything tab instead of spaced
within the customstreams.com?
No?
I
I I don't think so. No.
Okay.
Yeah.
Can you move our e our video images
a little bit down so I or Sorry.
Roll up the so
I can take a look at the code.
Yeah.
Okay. Create stream stream route code.
Okay. For the stream name, just put Rawkode.
I'm not sure if the unders I don't
remember if the underscore is.
Yeah. Create stream
Rawkode.
I'm breaking everything
there. Okay.
So create stream Rawkode.
Type, okay,
stream Rawkode.
Or you can put stream dot Rawkode.
Try that.
Yep.
From window tumbling fifteen
seconds.
Okay.
Anurag, do you think it's okay, that config?
Yeah. I think so. I think so.
It's it's pretty much the same one I
have. I think the only difference that I
have in my config is I have a
where clause at the end, but that's because,
like, I'm counting how many 200 errors I
experienced within Apache.
Okay. So I think I understand this now.
We're creating a new key in a config
map. It's called custom streams dot conf. So
we need to make sure that we load
that here, which we've got customstreams.com.
Mhmm. Can you add a new line after
the last SQL
query?
Yeah.
Okay.
There was a problem.
Interesting.
No changes that time. Let me make that
change again. I'm not sure why it said
there was a problem.
So we changed that, we replaced us with
a dot and we added a new line.
Okay. Yeah. Okay that time. Let's do the
delete one more time and I'm just gonna
check the daemon segments entire config map and
it's not selective. Although I guess it wouldn't
be, would it?
Cool. Looks like it is grabbing the default
one.
Oh, one one more thing. And the config
map, we forgot to modify is the input
needs to be stream dot
Rawkode as well.
Ah, okay.
So that CPU,
the tag. Yeah.
Oh, sorry. No. No. We're fine. It it's
it was fine as is. I'm I'm an
idiot. Sorry.
Okay. Alright. Cool. We're good. We should be
let's check the logs again then and see
if we're still getting any errors.
Oh, it's happy now. Oh, no. It still
it can't open this file.
Yeah. Still failing on that. It's odd.
It's a config map issue. Why?
Okay. So
let's try one more thing before we admit
defeat here. Okay? So you said I could
use a different image that would give me
a shell?
Yeah. Just append at the end dash deeper.
Alright. This one's gonna go first.
So in theory, I should be able to
oh, yeah. That one just died. Silly me.
Okay.
Let's grab
this one.
It's Alpine?
Yeah. Okay.
So the directory was and
then ATC
and we do not have our custom parsers
fail.
Let's check that map again
as a daemon set.
Yeah. These are all yeah. These are all
done as a sub paths. So
That's why. That's why.
Easy when you know how. Right? So streams
Yeah.
Name config
sub path custom.
Streams dot com.
Alright.
Let's see what we have.
I'm not sure if that four second one
is gonna be
I
mean we can check but I don't know
if that four second one was it terminating
from the last rollover
or not.
Yeah.
Probably not. Okay. So let's wait for the
next one which is just coming.
Alright.
Logs
f
and
let's try.
There we go. We have a stream. Stream
processor. Perfect. Started. Register task. Rawkode.
Let's be bold. Let's go to Kibana.
Okay. Let's see if this is gonna pick
that up. Maybe I need to refresh.
Oh, I'm not port forwarding, of course.
I was like, no.
So we might write a new tutorial for
this, you know, after this episode.
I I think, yeah, two things that I
see as good improvements. We should just add
stream processor files as part of the natural
helm charts.
So they're already there as per and as
the daemon set. So you can configure it
if you want it, but, you know, it's
empty if you don't need it.
Should we have to wait for
something to show up here?
Yeah. But it was fifteen seconds.
So
The window tumbling is fifteen seconds. I see.
I'm trying to think. We were ingesting the
raw code. We're doing account on fifteen seconds,
and then
it gets sent over.
Let me just
make sure we got happy Fluent bits.
Looks okay. Stream register task. So
this should be
let me open that conflict map one more
time.
That's the two instead.
So we created a stream which is
reading,
for creates a stream called Rawkode,
which is gonna rate new data with a
tag stream dot Rawkode.
And it's doing that based on anything that
comes through from a tag Rawkode.
And in order to facilitate the tag Rawkode,
we added a new output
here
which matches on Oh, it's it's streaming that
Rawkode.
There's no matching rule. Stream that Rawkode. Perfect.
That's excellent. Okay.
Alright.
Okay.
One more rotation. We should use this for
the session again. Right? To make it right.
I always find this kind of situation really
valuable, you know, because it just make sure
that you're not taking any assumptions. You understand
how to fix it, debug it. I think
there's a lot of value in understanding the
steps. Oh, absolutely. It's making a lot of
sense to me every time we change something,
I'm starting to get a picture how everything
comes together. So
yeah, let's get this port forward going. Wait
fifteen seconds and I'm sure we will have
everything we need.
I feel like I need to do like
a drum roll.
Hey. Look at that. There it is. Nice.
We got some numbers.
Alright. Let's connect
our timestamp field.
I'm assuming when we go to discover, is
this gonna show the counts?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think it so we
put count as
it's, like, total count or something?
Yeah.
I I think I changed the index on
the top left. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Bit queue.
There we go. Total count.
Perfect.
I see. Real time aggregation
from our stream of logs.
Yeah. There's there's some really cool functions in
there as well. So you can do, like,
max, you can do min, average
of, like, metric values. You can do
time series prediction.
So you can say predict sixty seconds in
the future or, you know, ten hours in
the future what my CPU or memory usage
look like.
But, yeah, basically does that. So is one
of the use cases that this would facilitate
then? Like, you know,
got a distributed architecture
running on Kubernetes and hundreds if not thousands
of micro services and I wanna do some
sort of crude anomaly detection based on the
number of messages over a given window pair
of service. That's just gonna allow me to
layer in real time based on that stream
of logs. Is that roughly what the use
case is here?
Exactly.
Is prediction,
anomaly detection,
as well as reducing data. Give me a
summary of the of the 10,000 logs that
just appeared,
and then send me the summary. Don't send
me those 10,000 raw logs.
Awesome.
That is that's great. Let
me pop back over here.
I think
well, for a start, you know, that's all
really, really cool. I'm I'm really happy with
what we got covered, what we showed off
there. Is there anything else that you wanna
show before we disappear? I am cautious that
I've taken up a lot of your time,
so I'll
I'll I'll leave it in No. Actually, are
really happy about all of this.
Yeah.
Well, I I think that we have a
couple of news to share. So from a
pre perspective,
Fluent Bit one dot seven, which is like
a major release, is coming out in a
few weeks. We are targeting the end of
this month, maybe February
based on
on testing QA.
Right? We're working very close with Google, Amazon,
Microsoft.
And because this release, what is really important
is about performance.
Right? Fluent Bit has been times faster than
Fluentd for data processing,
data delivery,
but usually, there are big users that say,
no. I want higher throughput higher throughput.
I have 48 CPUs. Why don't use at
least a fraction of them?
So Fluent Bit used to be like single
core a c it's a single core. Yeah.
One single thread.
While working, it does a lot of asynchronous
IO with coroutines.
So it does a pretty nice job on
scheduling all that stuff internally
without blocking.
But in some cases, you need I need
to you know that you need to increase
your your throughput.
And one of the most expensive things on
all this pipeline is, like, for example, when
we send the data to Elasticsearch,
we need to convert back our binary data
representation
in message effect, which is like a kind
of JSON but in binary
to the expected payload by elastic, and that
is JSON.
And that is really expensive.
You know, composed JSON string is really expensive.
So if you have one pipeline where you
are sending the data out,
you need to convert that. So and that
blocks, you know, the other operations.
So the improvement that we have been working
for the latest weeks is to add multithreading
support.
So right now, when you're going to run
your output plug into your output destination, optionally,
you can say, please create two workers for
this output.
And, generally, there will be two parallel,
like, threads. Right? That when you're going to
send the data, this data will be processed.
All the JSON composer will happen in separate
thread,
you know, and that increase the throughput by
I don't know, Anurag, how many times? Like,
five times, 10 times?
We're we're shooting for Crazy. For a lot.
Yeah. So, yeah, that comes out the end
of the month, and then we also have
a conference for,
Fluentcon.
That's gonna be side by side with KubeCon
Europe.
The CFPs or the call for proposals opens
up next week,
so we encourage folks to, to apply. We'd
love to see sessions about float d, float
bit,
and, yeah, you'll, of course, be able to
come learn a lot more, of of all
the use cases, how folks in financial security,
etcetera, are using all this. So
awesome.
Well, that's awesome. I'm really excited. Looking forward
to 1.7. I can't wait to bench in
all of the conference talks as well and
learn a whole lot more. Thank you both
for taking the time out of your day
and joining me today. Really impressed with the
software. Can't wait to see what comes next,
and I hope you all have a great
weekend.
Thanks. You as well. Thanks for all. Cheers.
Bye.
Thanks.